el mundo del deporte está siendo
sacudido por la guerra desde la invasión
a ucrania el deporte internacional se ha
movilizado para sancionar tanto a rusia
como a belarús debido a la creciente
presión la fifa y la uefa se han visto
obligadas a prohibir competir a los
equipos rusos en consecuencia rusia ha
sido expulsada de la fase de
clasificación para el mundial y el
spartak de moscú de la europa league y
no sólo los equipos rusos se han visto
afectados el propietario del chelsea
roman abramovich puso en venta el club
debido a sus históricos vínculos con
vladimir putin la final de la liga de
campeones en la gran cita del fútbol
europeo se ha trasladado de san
petersburgo a parís los juegos
paralímpicos que empezaron el viernes
también se han visto afectados sus
organizadores insistieron inicialmente
en que no tenían otra opción que
permitir a los atletas rusos y bien los
rusos competir bajo una bandera neutral
un día más tarde y tras las protestas de
sus compañeros la decisión fue revocada
en el mundo de la fórmula 1 la guerra
tenía un efecto drástico a sólo dos
semanas de empezar la temporada del 2022
el equipo hash está sumido en la
confusión este ha roto lazos con su
principal inversor dmitri math epping
cercano a vladimir putin su hijo nikita
uno de los dos pilotos del equipo fue
despedido pocos días después los
deportes individuales como el atletismo
y el esquí han prohibido a todos los
competidores rusos y bien los rusos
mientras que la federación internacional
de tenis ha adoptado una postura algo
más suave permite que los individuos
compitan bajo una bandera neutral aunque
también ha cancelado todos sus próximos
torneos en rusia a medida que las
sanciones siguen llegando a todos los
ámbitos los efectos en el deporte ruso
se sentirán durante mucho tiempo